we have new developments in our
investigation into toxic drinking water
at a marine corps base in north carolina
nearly two dozen veterans came forward
after our story last month about sick
children at camp lejeune the veterans
describe a broken v.a claims system cbs
news found cases where the va agreed
illnesses were more likely than not to
be connected to the base's contaminated
water but only after it was too late
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herrich has been following the
story and joins us from the pentagon
catherine good morning
good morning nate to evaluate these
claims the v.a uses so-called subject
matter experts our cbs news
investigative team found doctors who
lacked expertise in relevant medical
fields and veterans who spent years in
the appeals process
about a year after he got out of the
marines he started having problems with
his balance
stumbling
and then he lost his hearing patty
metzler is talking about her father dave
in the late 1950s he spent 34 months at
camp lejeune a marine base in north
carolina
on a driving tour of north jackson ohio
we're coming up on the prison that i
work at patty a nurse practitioner
showed us where her dad once worked as a
machine repairman so this is the gm
plant here until he got too sick patty
says his failing health became a
liability i know that depressed him
because he went through a phase where he
felt like
i'm no longer the person to support my
family the u.s government acknowledges
that from 1953 to 1987 nearly a million
veterans and civilians who lived at camp
lejeune were potentially exposed to
dangerous chemicals in the drinking
water in some areas it was 400 times
what safety standards allowed there's a
lot of pictures here dave filed a claim
with the v.a to connect his neurological
problems to his service at camp lejeune
if approved the metzlers would receive
much needed financial support he was
denied in 2014 and again in 2015. he did
get depressed
he got angry and
he did attempt suicide once
fed up paddy did her own research and
got his case in front of a v.a judge
then waited based on your experience is
the va system working no not at all
it's completely failing veterans mike
wishny runs the veterans legal services
clinic at yale law school his students
filed a lawsuit in 2016 on behalf of
camp lejeune veterans seeking more
information about the doctors who review
camp lejeune claims they're known as
subject matter experts or smes not all
of them appeared to have the
qualifications for the job they were
doing cbs news reviewed va records and
in some cases found general medicine
doctors not experts but after they
started this program the approval rate
which was already low went even lower
according to government transcripts and
documents obtained by cbs news the rate
plummeted from 25 to 5 percent the
saying is denied and i deny until they
die
retired lieutenant colonel mark
cottenhauer a lifelong aviator is two
years into his own battle with the va to
connect his pancreatic and prostate
cancers with his service at camp lejeune
how many doctors have blamed your cancer
on the contaminated water at camp
lejeune seven
seven doctors still the va denied
cottnaur's claim on the basis that their
subject matter expert was more
persuasive why would the va side with a
general medicine expert over a group of
cancer specialists they don't want to
step up and do the right thing cotton
hour is appealing and says it's not
about the money the marine corps and the
va needs to be accountable to the
marines and the sailors and all those
people at lucha
and they haven't been are you expecting
a decision from the va in your lifetime
you know my appeal now is 18 months old
i i'm hoping to hear you know before
in my lifetime but you're no guarantee
in dave messler's claim the subject
matter expert specialized in preventive
medicine the subject matter expert that
looked at his case knew nothing about
neurology in 2018 a v.a judge overruled
the earlier denials
on her dining room wall hangs the framed
va approval letter granting her dad a
hundred percent disability but dave
never lived to see this victory he died
14 months earlier about a week prior to
his death he was still lucid and talking
and i had some time alone with him
and he gave me a hug
and said don't give up
keep fighting
i promised him i would
dave messler's widow is receiving
survivors benefits but the family is
still fighting the v.a over back pay in
a statement to cbs news the v.a says
it's committed to the processing of all
claims to ensure priority veterans are
served as timely and accurately as
possible they also told us the doctors
in these cases had quote appropriate
credentials and received four hours of
training on issues relevant to the
evaluations and while the va
acknowledges the average approval rate
is now 17
their own data shows that the approval
rate dropped dramatically once they
started using these experts and more
than half of the outstanding claims are
now considered backlog michelle
an important report thank you for your
reporting catherine uh i just
it's hard to look at this and not think
of how we respect our veterans in public
and then to see them ask for help
medical help for time served and not get
it those who proudly serve this country
and for him to say
it's denied deny deny until we die
you're doing something wrong if you're
leaving that impression in the minds of
the people you're supposed to be taken
care of